you teased that there was going to be
like a shocking amount of Cliffhangers
in Emily in Paris season three and man
did you deliver my goodness I'm gonna go
down the list can me and Gabrielle's
wedding off I'm sorry
but I can't marry you kemmy is pregnant
congratulations
she came back to tell me that
Alfie breaks up with Emily from nobody's
second choice Cooper now go get you man
Emily and Gabrielle finally admit they
have feelings for each other and there's
still a few more that I didn't even
mention your feelings for me
they've always been there it's been hard
for me too so I want to know which
Cliffhanger shocked you the most oh the
pregnant one yeah I was like the baby
because now it's like oh there's a baby
involved like we're all in over our head
I heard all the endings and thought they
were like alts then I realized they were
all the endings at one and I was like
wait there's a wedding and then there's
a wedding that doesn't happen or there's
engagement that turns into a wedding
which turns into a non-wedding which
turns into a pregnancy announcement
which turned into like what the what now
commis storyline at the end is like what
you know Emily in Paris baby oh my God
what's going on here it was like you
know okay oh yeah that was like whoa
that's a big one I think that the
biggest shock for me was
um was Cami at the altar kind of giving
it to Gabriel that was kind of whoa and
her performance in that was truly
stunning it puts you on a hell of a
cliffhanger to see what's going to come
next obviously I don't expect that yeah
and I think now what's gonna happen for
Gabriel for Kami for the other girl for
you know it's a mess like it's sad for
healthy but like finally she's with
Gabriel and like and boom ah when I read
it I was like oh okay season Four's
gonna be funny yeah from the moment we
get into that church uh it's just what
uh sorry um
okay I'm back wait okay it feels like a
big firework the way Alfie leaves the
church is very strong the way me leaves
me on at the altar and that last scene
with Emily is just we were so focused
you know and when Darren told me you
have the last word this season I felt
invested with a mission you know I felt
like my country is behind me I won't
receive it's always very alive on set on
Emily and that night you could hear the
Flies
and we were just in silence what a mess
my goodness we finally have an
opportunity for Gabrielle and Emily to
give it a real shot do you see them
doing that in season four or do you
think she should go fight to get her man
Alfie back I don't know Emily has had to
fight to win Alfie back once so I don't
know if that's gonna happen again I
don't know how Alfie feels about that I
don't know where Gabrielle sits because
we've expressed feelings but there's a
baby on the way there are so many
unknowns that I think the the
representation of Emily's face at the
end of the season which was just so
filled with emotion that it ends up
being just quite blank you and I spoke
Lucas in in April and you said I am 100
team Alfie yes I'm 100 team Alfie are
you still team Alfie or have you
switched I think uh Alfie brought this
antagonist perspective on Paris because
it doesn't bind to the hype of Paris so
I feel like it kind of It kind of
leveled Emily back to a very normal it
made her more French and Parisian and
less impressed with the architecture and
and the ways and I like the dynamic that
it brought into the shows and and also
it seems brilliant in this in this role
so you told me in April that you
yes I'm team Gabrielle 100 you see his
eyes his eyes light up the room and take
care bro you are are we still are we
still team Gabriel but I just want her
to be happy she doesn't she deserves to
be happy yeah good diplomatic yeah I'm
on team love which is a little corny but
true team Emily figure it out the best
we want Emily to be happy
why are you laughing what's going on I
think all those relationships are toxic
they should just get away start over
oh it's a man what's wrong with these
people yes yeah yeah about the same time
we want them to sit in the same Circle
so we get drama you know correct yes
she's in love with Gabriel deeply okay
so your team Gabrielle
okay you just want Emily to be happy yes
exactly that's what I tried to say thank
you for the help I'd get Alfie back
Gabrielle doesn't know what he wants
oh I like that when you push indecision
away
people are indecisive like bye bye bye
bye yeah Alfie is super clear he's super
charming and I think that that's why
sometimes people are like I don't know
Alfie is he too Charming is they but he
is charismatic Jeremy yeah he's but he
is very grounded and he's like I know
what I want super clear so choose the
guy always that knows what he wants as a
mother I would say choose Alfie
what are you saying Brigade to
Eurovision oh my God
okay so we not only have your love
triangle congratulations you're now in
the Love Triangle Club
these guys for two seasons being like
guys figure it out and now she jokes
jokes on her so like you mentioned you
know things are going well with Nikola
but like now she's got this Eurovision
opportunity with Benoit where do you see
Mindy's heart at going into season four
I really don't I really don't know
either like that's that's the big
question obviously we I I love that we
got to focus on this like relationship
and deepening that in the second half of
the season and not so much in the Music
World
um I don't know I feel like a lot of oh
these guys all need to catch up what is
going on so I really don't know I really
yeah I'm just excited for Eurovision I
know yeah yeah is there gonna be a baby
in season four is Gabrielle about to
become a father how do you see that
storyline playing out well I think
Gabrielle I think it's very clear from
in season three that that's a it's a big
dream of his totally he wants to be a
father and I think he he's excited was
excited and is excited about the idea of
fatherhood but you know our show doesn't
it doesn't move that quickly six months
of actual time so I'm I'm not sure we
I'm not sure we're gonna actually see a
baby in season four interesting but I
think that we're gonna have to deal with
the prospect of a baby another belly yes
from Kate to commit yes exactly amazing
yeah well I'll wear the bump beautifully
yes not not so fast though not so fast
okay are you going to be wearing a baby
bump in season four are you ready for an
Emily in Paris baby uh I hope no I hope
not why
um because I I don't know
for the fashion wise uh thing I think
it's better to be I don't know have you
seen Kate yeah yeah okay Katie's rocking
it but it's huge so it's cute when it's
just a little bit I don't think I don't
know oh you will look so good I don't
know we'll see maybe it'll be like Fast
forwarded a year and we'll just have a
baby
who's like a casting copper or maybe
it's twins yeah oh my God stop it guys
yeah well welcoming a little a little
baby tear set I mean is that something
that excites you uh not at all you know
what I did a shooting once with the baby
and I think that's very hard and
stressful because I'm always uh very
afraid to hurt it oh you put that and
I'm like I'm sorry I'm sorry like I kind
of deal with babies I love them but I
don't know how to do it all right well
buckle up Mom you're welcome buckle up
not mean you won't you'll yeah yeah
you'll do a great job you do a great job
foreign